um dropped slightly in
yes that's right uh inflation and the
consumer price index measure came in at
9.9 percent in august that was down from
10.1
in july slightly unexpected the market
had been looking for around 10 10.1
this is actually the first drop in
inflation that we've seen since
september last year since september 2021
now the key reason behind it was a drop
in petrol prices during the month they
fell by around 14.3 pence per liter but
there are still lots of other things
contributing to higher inflation food
inflation for example during the month
well that was 13.1 percent up from 12.7
in july that was up down to a higher
milk cheese and egg prices in particular
clothing and footwear inflation that was
six seven point six percent during the
month up from six point six percent the
office for national statistics came
pointing out that uh actually there are
a few anomalies there related to covet
you always get a rise in uh clothing
prices this time of year because the
autumn ranges come into the shops and
the summer sales come to an end but they
think that was slightly distorted by
what was happening in the stores last
year with covid so on the whole while it
looks encouraging there's certainly
plenty more inflation to come producer
price inflation which is a key driver
well that was still 20 and a half
percent meanwhile core inflation now
this is the measure that strips out
volatile elements such as energy tobacco
and food well that came in at six point
three percent that was actually up from
six point two percent last month so
there is still plenty of inflationary
pressure in the system most analysts
don't think we're going to get a peak
until october of course which is when we
get uh this rise in energy prices on the
uh price cap what extent that will be
affected by the measures unveiled by liz
trust and her government last thursday
remain to be seen most people as i say
don't expect inflation to peak until at
least october of this year